(Ari)
Ladies and gentlemen,
a very funny woman.
Ms. Iliza Shlesinger, everybody.
Let her hear it.
[cheers and applause]
Because I fly so much,
I have a rule, and that is:
never talk to the person sitting
next to you on an airplane.
This rule instated after
I shared a lovely hour-long
flight to San Jose with a woman
who just pretty much spent
the whole time telling me
why Jews are the source of
all the problems in the world.
So...
[exhales]
So I never talk to
the people sitting next to me.
And I was flying home
about a year ago
and a boy sat next to me.
He was about my age, clean cut.
He started chatting,
and he seemed normal.
So, I asked him about himself.
I'm like,
"Tell me about yourself."
He's like,
"Well, my name is Brian.
I work at a hedge fund
and I went to Yale."
I was like, "Okay, nerd alert."
[chuckles]
And he was like,
"Tell me about yourself."
I was like, "My name's Iliza,
I'm a standup comedian,
and I struggle with being
attractive, yet accessible."
So, over the next couple weeks
we kind of became friends.
We stayed in touch.
We'd hang out a lot.
And I liked him.
I liked his personality.
He was a hard worker,
Irish American,
hard worker, smart.
And it became clear
that he had a crush on me.
He would always try
to buy me drinks,
always buy things to impress me.
He bought a house at one point.
Not for me, but he bought one.
I never went over,
'cause I didn't want to,
you know,
see him with his shirt off
'cause I could tell that
his body was unacceptable.
And I think it bothered him that
I didn't have a crush on him.
And I was like,
let me explain it to you.
I am a seven without makeup,
and you are a four with money.
Those are the numbers,
crunch them as you will.
So, one day
he called me and he was like,
"We can't hang out today.
My mother has been
diagnosed with cancer."
I stopped dead in my tracks
and for some reason,
something in my heart opened up
and all I wanted to do
was take care of him.
This is a man
that had done nothing
but be kind to me,
and be sweet to me.
So, I was like,
"What do you want to do?
"Can I take you somewhere?
Can I take your mom somewhere?
"You want to cry?
I'm crying right now.
"That's a weird
chemical imbalance,
but I feel bad for you."
I just wanted to
be there for him.
And over the next
couple of weeks,
I started to
fall in love with him.
And we dated for about a week
and things were great.
And then things got weird.
My mom called me one day.
[hoarse voice, New York accent]
"Eliza.
I Googled your boyfriend."
Incidentally, my mother
is Selma, from The Simpsons.
[applause]
"And on his company bio,
it doesn't say he went to Yale.
It says University of Ohio."
Fine institution,
but it ain't Yale.
So, I called my boyfriend.
I was like,
"Why doesn't it say Yale?
"You talk about Yale
all the time.
"You seem pretty proud of it.
Why doesn't it say it
on your bio?"
He was like, "Oh, my God.
If you saw the way
"things were run
at this company, it's a mess.
It's a nightmare.
I'm leaving anyway."
And I was like, "Totally.
I got it.
[Bleep] the man, yeah,
I got it."
People mess up my bio
all the time.
Sometimes they don't put winner
of Last Comic Standing.
Sometimes they put winner
of America's Next Top Model.
Do I correct it?
No.
I just let audiences be
disappointed
with my lack of facial symmetry.
Whatever.
I was like, "All right, well,
I'm gonna make you
"some cupcakes.
I'm gonna bring them
"to your house.
I haven't seen it yet.
This is gonna be fun."
He's like, "Well, bring them
to my office."
I was like, "No, I'll bring them
"to your house.
Your office is on the,
ugh, West Side."
So...
He gives me the address, and as
I'm driving toward his house,
I'm noticing
it's not in Beverly Hills,
which is where he said
he bought a house.
It's in Hollywood.
And as I pull up,
I notice it's not so much
a house as it is a duplex.
So, thinking
I've made a mistake,
I go up to the window
and I look in.
Looking for context clues.
Looking for some things of his,
Yale context clues, right?
Plaid, mallards, pennants,
minorities chained to a window,
something.
And none of that was in there.
And before I could leave,
a girl opened the door.
And we locked eyes and she goes,
"You're Iliza."
I was like, "Who are you?"
She goes, "I'm Mary.
I'm Brian's roommate."
I was like, "Hm."
So I call my boyfriend.
And I was like,
"What's up, bro?
What's up with the roommate
and non-house?"
He was like, "Um, okay.
"This is weird,
but I have a house.
"Um, my mom lives in it while
she undergoes cancer treatment.
"And I don't bother her because
we don't really get along
and I want to give her
her space."
And I was like,
"I totally get that.
But I need to know
where you [bleep] live."
So, he comes over and he goes,
"Here's my address.
Here's my mom's phone number.
"You have everything.
"I just ask that you respect--
basically a woman's dying wish
it to be left alone."
And I was like, "Fine, double
dog dare me not to be crazy.
I'll take that bet.
Fine."
So, a couple weeks go by,
I let it lie.
I'm on my way to the airport
to fly to a gig
and my mother calls me.
[hoarsely]
"Eliza.
"I called
the Yale registrar's office.
"They have no record
of your Brian
ever having attended Yale."
So my first thought is,
"Maybe they misspelled Brian
over there at Yale.
"Maybe they wrote Brain.
Maybe they made a mistake
and he did go there."
So I hang up.
I call my boyfriend.
And on my way to calling him,
it's ringing
and I decide to take out
that piece of paper
that had his address on it.
The one I was told
to stay away from.
And I drive by that house
in Beverly Hills.
And I'm about to get out
and knock on the door
or something just to bother
his mom for a second,
and I see a black family
come out with their kids,
load them into the van.
Now, Brian is Irish,
but he wasn't black Irish.
So, I call him.
He picks up and I was like, "You
are lying about many things.
"I don't know what they are,
but I'm not signing up
for the next round of this.
I'm out of here."
And that's when
it all came crashing down.
He said,
"I can't do this anymore.
"Um...
"I didn't go to Yale.
"And I never bought a house.
"I just said it to impress you.
"Also...
My mother doesn't have cancer."
Right?
You've never been more annoyed
that someone
doesn't have cancer.
So, for the last six or--
[laughter]
For the last
six or seven months,
I've really wrestled with this.
It's a traumatic thing,
and I've really tried to
figure out a spiritual meaning.
Some sort of life lesson
I can extrapolate from this
and use in a healthy way
for the rest of my life.
And after all is said and done,
the life lesson I've learned is,
um...
Never talk to the person sitting
next to you on an airplane.
Actually,
if we have time for this,
I think I've also taught
a life lesson.
And that is, if you're gonna
mess with someone
because you're a crazy person,
try not messing
with a standup comedian
who has access to
a national television show.
Go [bleep] yourself,
Brian [bleep].
Thank you.
[cheers and applause]